ولدت ماما إسراء في اليوم الذي
دخلت فيه الهدنة حيز التنفيذ منذ وقت طويل على ما يبدو،
وهي تعيش مع والديها وشقيقها
في مأوى مؤقت في
دي وهي تفتقر إلى أساسيات الحياة بسبب
البرد في الشتاء، وتقول والدتها التي
تحمل اسم
هذه العائلة الشابة أيضًا  جزء من 1.9
مليون شخص (85٪ من سكان غزة
الذين نزحوا ولكنهم
لا يزالون في
خطر الدخان يرتفع فوق رفح حيث
فر الكثير من الناس حتى بعد ظهر الأربعاء،
تم قصف هذا المنزل في مخيم رفح للاجئين
حتماً في مثل هذا
المكان المزدحم وكان الأطفال من بين
القتلى)  لا يوجد مكان آمن في غزة
يقول أنه يمكن ضرب أي مكان
تقول وزارة الصحة الفلسطينية إن
أكثر من 20 شخصًا قتلوا في
الغارة، بما في ذلك 17 فردًا من
نفس
العائلة الممتدة، أخبروهم أن الجنوب آمن، لقد
أتوا إلى هنا في المكان الآمن
وكانوا كذلك  يقول جميع القتلى
بسام إن الموت يطارد الآن كل ركن من أركان
هذه
الأرض في هان يونس، وهو محور
الهجوم الإسرائيلي الحالي، والمستشفى مكتظ
بالجرحى، ومع ذلك يأتي المزيد، ويقول
مبعوث منظمة الصحة العالمية إلى غزة إنهم يفعلون ما في
وسعهم ولكن البنية التحتية الصحية  جاثي على
ركبتيه، إنه على وشك الانهيار،
هذا هو الواقع، إنه على وشك
الانهيار، الانهيار، الفوضى، الدمار،
والموت، هذا هو حال غزة بن ويدمان
سي إن إن
القدس